well hello there reject nation looks
like we got ourselves a film theory we
got ourselves a film theory a todd
theory film theory about dr strange
multiverse of madness what's this one
called it's called why you're wrong
about multiverse of madness parentheses
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness all right guys
let's get to it and see what matpat and
the gang has to say today
[Music]
so doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness huh no sooner did steven strange
make all the peter parker related
problems go for giddy bye with plot
magic and apparently the whole
multiverse gets broke to heck and this
time strange has got himself mortal
problems witch problems and even more
octopus problems plus a brand new
variant of himself showing up causing
problems maybe this sequel has had one
of the most troubled developments of any
phase 4 marvel cinematic universe movie
it was one of the first ones announced
it was one of the earliest to be delayed
because of the pandemic the original
writer director team left during
pre-production so sam raimi took over
there have apparently been multiple
significant rewrites and reshoots taking
place during the various pandemic
related delays and what's even more
unusual no one really knows what's
happening with the film itself even
extremely basic elements like which
actors are appearing in it what's it
basically about have been on a lockdown
so harsh that you'd think the literal
tva were involved but now armed with a
teaser i think there's enough in there
that team theorists can predict what's
going to happen in this thing prior to
it
the track record for calling marvel
stuff as of late has been pretty solid
so can we keep our streak going ladies
and gentlemen strap in because you're
about to learn just how mad the
multiverse can get let's just start with
the top line overview of what this
trailer gives us doctor strange knows
about something that's caused havoc in
the multiverse it looks like mordo who
in case you forgot took off to go wizard
hunting at the end of the first doctor
strange movie is back to call him out on
it something unleashes a
lego giant league is meant to be the
villain gargantos yeah i heard some
rumors and i think they did want to use
schumacher i think there's like
licensing right so they ended up having
to go with gargantos instead and
honestly nine times out of ten if you
show me a side-by-side photo i can't
tell the difference
you gotta learn all your tentacle beasts
before they all show up all of it leads
strange to seek out the help from the
scarlet witch before uh-oh this thing is
gonna have itself a mirror match against
an evil doctor strange variant and
that's about it seeing me now if you
[ __ ] up with the smaller screen mcu
you'll know that in the anthology series
what if one of its breakout reimagined
characters was strange supreme a dark
tragic and way overpowered multiverse
variant of doctor strange whose powers
come from having absorbed the spirits of
hundreds of demons including wouldn't
you know a giant octopus that shot one
minute and 38 seconds into the teaser of
a doctor strange throwing two serpents
at someone yeah that looks a lot like
one of strange supreme's attacks from
what if so is this him and if so then
what's he doing here well first answer
no i don't think it's him by the end of
what if strange supreme is actually
redeemed so bringing him back to be evil
just feels off plus you'll notice that
this strange appears to be missing a
hand maybe oh look marvel likes to fake
us out with trailers like they did with
interesting
this shot yeah looks like he's a hand
down but then here it looks like he
might just be holding it behind his back
that being said i think there's a good
chance it's gone can't pull a fast one
on me marvel we can and you have
multiple times in the past but not this
time hand imagery is everywhere around
this guy which matters considering one
strange supreme had both hands the first
doctor strange movie was all about
stephen recovering the use of his hands
after a severe injury as a result it
kind of makes it seem like this might be
a doctor strange variant that wasn't
able to recover the use of both of his
hands i'd also be remiss if i didn't
call out that sam raimi is directing
this one who ironically enough has got
himself
directing movies where wisecracking
heroes lose a hand and then ultimately
end up fighting their evil twin
groovy are you me i'm badass and you're
good ash your goody little two shoes
good
bad i'm the guy with a gun that's the
evil dead series by the way in case you
were wondering if you're ever in need
for a horror or horror comedy check them
out i think what that moment just did
was get me really excited at the
prospect of sam raimi stepping back in
to deal with multiple versions of the
same character actor like benedict
cumberbatch who would know how to
differentiate distinguish them all and
have fun
i don't know how many variants we get of
doctor's race
that would be cool he brings up a really
great point as to why that wouldn't be
strange supreme because i i've been sold
on strange that had strange supreme this
entire time when he brought the whole
thing with redemption oh yeah that's
true yeah well and that's the thing is i
feel like it might be an obvious pool to
go oh strange supreme but i don't know i
feel like the possibility is just as
great that we'll see various other
strangers that aren't that one but that
are equally as sinister or as out there
and interesting what is evil doctor
strange here for well did you happen to
notice the girl wearing the patriotic
denim jacket walking around the sanctum
america seconds into the trailer that my
friends is america chavez aka miss
america how do we narrow the gap between
the rich and the poor
and she is complicated an adventurous
teenager raised by her two moms in a
women-only superhuman pocket dimension
she's got superhuman strength the power
of flight and relevant to our interests
today the power to open portals and jump
across the multiverse at will not just
any portals either portals in the shape
of a star just like we see right here in
the trailer ah it's just funny because i
remember like we did some video recently
where people were talking about doctor
strange you're gonna be woking this up
by putting america's chavez in here i'm
like you mean to tell me you can't even
adapt a character from the coffee
station
yeah it's not even the first comic book
character to come from an all-female
realm of super demigods so like what's
the big deal
it's in the source material as you can
imagine powers like this make her a
frequent target for bad guys in the
comics so it would make sense that mordo
or someone else would be after that kind
of power in this new movie especially
since she's young and as a result not
likely to have mastered her skills yet
enter dr strange as her mentor and
protector
yeah okay i get it i hear ya where am i
getting that america chavez is in
trouble or that strange is gonna be
helping her she doesn't get named or say
anything in the trailer she doesn't even
get name dropped in international plot
summaries of the movie and yep you got
us that part is us taking a swing
strictly based on context clues that you
see in the trailer she's a younger
character in a movie otherwise full of
grown-ups we see her walking cautiously
or jumping out of harm's way strange
seems to be positioning himself in front
of her or between her
[Music]
protecting a wayward child from another
world is kind of a standard superhero
plus given that this is technically also
a sequel to spiderman no way home now
it's easy to picture strange feeling the
need for some personal redemption
involving teenagers in over their heads
with the multiverse yeah two of them
were definitely not teenagers yep
that went up on screen
he doesn't need another grown man and
another pretty grown man pretty sure
distracted men younger than what
that's probably just enter edinger
visual reference terms of like showing
the spider-man maybe let's talk about mj
ned and peter america's his mj but you
know that's a good point i didn't even
think about that i thought like she'd
just be someone who's on the team
helping out especially what was revealed
with the concept art that america chavez
was supposed to originally be in
spider-man no way home then i thought
she'd just be someone a part of the team
but it looks like he is gonna have to
protect her with those shots because
they're gone i didn't catch that so
doctor strange is protecting america's
chavez from a dark version of himself
maybe but i don't think that's quite the
full case enter wanda now since the
beginning many people including us have
predicted that she'll be some sort of
villain in this movie one division ended
with her on a big emotional downswing
where are my children her kids and her
husband are ripped away from her so she
ends the series looking through a book
of dark magic to find a way back to him
she also learns during the movie's final
battle that she's now stronger than the
sorcerer supreme no one taught me magic
your power exceeds that of the sorcerer
supreme it's your destiny
destroy the world which you know is just
them basically telegraphing a battle
between her and strange it would
parallel her narrative arc from the
house of m comics the movie secretly
spells out the word mom i mean there is
a lot here that we've actually gone more
in depth about in a previous episode but
now in this new trailer we have some
more clues we see wanda casting magic
and this little detail see your
fingertips they're black just like in
the harkness
her fingers get more and more black but
wanda's fingers in that same battle
remain the same meaning that here in
doctor strange two where her fingers are
now black wanda is tapping into that
same evil magic that agatha was using oh
crap you're so right i thought that was
i thought that was um
uh you know when people paint their
fingernails
you should go through a picture
rebelling
i didn't notice that whoa that's a great
detail both oh you guys are catching it
and just as like a script supervision
thing and now that we know that this new
movie features a girl who can rip
portals through the multiverse it seems
like a desirable skill for a grieving
mother that's looking to locate her kids
that are lost somewhere in an alternate
universe so wanda is looking to explain
the powers of miss america to find her
kids with dr strange trying to hold her
back prompting the inevitable wizard
battle between the two that's probably
why we never see all three of them on
screen at the same time but for his
confidence oh
i get where you're going with this world
events remember this sequel is coming
out six years after the original doctor
strange and in the downtime it's not
only changed its entire writing and
directing teams a few times over the
order of where it's meant to fall in the
phase 4 mcu sequence has also changed
but the biggest changes of all in this
time have come from society when in 2017
the metoo movement rocked entertainment
and politics and got people to seriously
evaluate the way women in modern media
are being portrayed including i would
expect in the mcu you might remember
that a lot of people including us were
sure that doctor strange was going to
show up at the end of juan division to
tease multiverse of madness and even
though he ultimately didn't it turns out
that at one point in time we were right
in an interview about the series with
rolling stone kevin feige himself
revealed that the crossover was cut to
avoid diminishing the strong female
character quote marvels struck a deal
with benedict cumberbatch to appear in
the final episode of the show as doctor
strange but late in the process they
wrote him out it would have taken away
from wanda which is what we didn't want
to do here's the white guy let me show
you how power works which in turn also
meant that doctor strange 2 had to be
rewritten as well as you might imagine
in a post metoo world the usual wanda
house of em story of a young powerful
mother going crazy and ripping reality
apart looking for her kids rides a um a
questionable line pr wise especially
considering how twitter's always looking
for the next thing to rage tweet about
and looking to the end of wandavision
wanda as a young woman with multiverse
breaking powers that she's not fully in
control of yet no longer makes sense
with the more self-reliant empowered way
her characters define in that scenario
then it would make a lot of sense for
rewrites to make the endangered powerful
person be a younger character with
multiverse specific powers america
chavez thereby leaving wanda as
as
well honestly as anything maybe she's
helping him maybe she's still the cause
of whatever america seems to be in
danger by or maybe she's both because
again it's a multiverse based off what
we were talking about here she'd be
using america's chavez yeah in order to
hop through multiverses in order to like
locate our children yeah create some
kind of kidnap scenario that's
understandable but also
friction heavy they didn't just
introduce you know uh
elizabeth olsen into the mcu she's been
around for a while she has a character
where she starts going like banana
sandwich i don't know i i guess as a guy
talking maybe i'm not the qualified one
to talk about it but to me i'm no you
are it's in the community i know i
always are because i'm a person of color
so i get a pass on to talking to a woman
right yeah that's the way it goes you
were absolved of all your realness it
makes the most sense
i think they've planted the seeds for
the herd to they had a whole season of
one division you know yes the
inspiration from the comics it's all
about execution it's like thanos in the
comics it's like i'm the bad guy
i didn't
like he's he's got a diabolical plan
essentially but at the same time he's
not like just maniacal as good as all
hell yeah we got the thanos's right
movement
grounded it a little bit and yeah i
wonder too because it's all just how
well you draw the character and i can
imagine with all the events we've seen
wanda go through the yeah it wouldn't
seem out of nowhere or like some kind of
silly trope for her to have a
antagonistic turn of some kind in
pursuit of her lost children probably
heard tons of absolutely wild stuff
flying around about this movie
introductions of other supernatural
marvel mainstays like moon knight blade
and ghost rider quicksilver coming back
for real this time rumors that patrick
stewart and hugh jackman have gone back
and forth on whether or not their
respective mutant characters would
somehow cameo here even stuff that's
truly outlandish like a variant iron man
played by tom cruise her fun fact
had that role in a different project
from a few years before robert downey jr
in fact as recently as november
multiverse madness underwent another
significant round of major reshoots the
assumption is that this is to add more
cameos and crossovers for legacy
nostalgia characters people who change
their minds after seeing the massively
positive reactions to spider-man no way
home's hype machine no sure half of this
stuff sounds like goofy fan fiction but
here's the thing all of it fits with one
group in the comics the illuminati the
the marvel illuminati just so we're
clear algorithms
you know illuminati was the name of a
secret society from a few centuries ago
that's still popularly used as shorthand
today for scary organization behind the
curtain in marvel comics though it's the
informal name for the secret club of
team leader rich guy and political
figure superhero types we're talking the
team leader for each major marvel
faction folks like your mr fantastics
your professor x's your iron mans and
your dr strange's their job basically to
act as the united nations for super
people to meet up behind the scenes and
share important information with each
other to keep the world stable now
that's the comics and it doesn't quite
work with movies because everything's
out in the open but instead what if
there was an illuminati of the
multiverse powerful figures who are
aware maybe the only people in their
respective timelines who are aware that
the multiverse exists and they take it
upon themselves to patch the cracks or
deal with troublemakers almost like the
tv
in an already packed movie a really
efficient way to make something like
this work would be to build it from a
mix of alternate versions of characters
we know like a dark version of steven
strange actors reprising their classic
roles from other movies new faces and
different roles like hey it's iron man
but he's being played by a different guy
and of course characters who don't need
any introduction in the first place now
this isn't a theory just because it
sounds cool now we get here because it
fits the rumors while also making
thematic sense for what we see in the
trailer steven strange just got done
with an adventure where his recklessness
nearly blew up the multiverse it got
someone killed it seriously altered
dozens of people's lives whether he
remembers all fragments or none of it
because of that memory wipe he has got
some serious explaining to do something
that we actually hear reflected back to
him in the trailer
so in a hypothetical scenario where
doctor strange is dealing with a teenage
girl who can portal between universes a
scarlet witch who wants to rip universes
apart to get her family back and a
multiverse illuminati who thinks all of
this is too dangerous and needs to be
eliminated sounds like suddenly we have
steven able to apply the lessons that he
learned from spider-man he gets a
do-over of sorts all with a boatload of
cameos and callbacks while setting up a
compelling extremely human and morally
complex storyline to ground the action
in and all of that from just waiting
past the credits hold on i couldn't just
watch it on youtube darn it anyway it's
all just a theory a film theory and
cuts
first time remember about so many
different cameos at this point i'm like
i don't know wrong
i can't guess them
it's like with spider-man you know
they're the rumors were just mainly
spider-man related characters and then
here like you could pull from like
literally
anything or
reference comic book reverence whatever
you want
yeah like even just this week alone you
know i had someone sent me about like
tom cruise is is in it and then same day
tom cruise is not in it and i'm like
okay reliable so i guess i'll just guess
i'll just wait to see if tom curtis is
in it or not one and two they've re-shot
this movie so many times now that i have
to imagine that there are like a million
combos that we will have never ever
had the opportunity to see that's true
that's true all right guys so thanks for
being here you can subscribe click that
bell hit that like button and uh film
theory great job team you all put
together another beautiful one as well
editing remarkable as usual matpat yeah
i guess it's all theories here
absolutely
it's almost as if they're professionals
yeah for the whole team to put this
together